[تصفيق]
تتعدد الوسائل والغايه واحده سحق اصوات
تندد بواقع لا يحتمل في ايران يبتكر جهاز
الامن طرق تعذيب ممنهجه لفضل الاحتجاجات
المستمره منذ مقتل رمز الثوره ماسه اميني
سبتمبر الماضي شبكه سي ان ان تتبعت خيوط
شهادات اوصلتها بسلسله غامضه من المعتقلات
السريه في جميع انحاء ايران 30 موقعا
الكثير منها يقع داخل منشات حكوميه كقواعد
للجيش وللحرس الثوري الايراني والقليل
داخل مستودعات او غرف فارغه في مباني او
اقبيه مساجد هنا في شمال شرق ايران في
مشهد تم تحديده ثلاثه مواقع سوداء اليها
جر المتظاهرون مع صبور اعين وتعرضوا لضرب
مبرح وانتهى بهم الامر بكسر في الانف واح
في الاذرع او في الضلوع
المعتقلون ذكروا تفاصيل العنف الجنسي
والسعي بالكهرباء وخلع المسامير والجلد
والضرب المبرح الذي يتعرضوا له كل ذلك
تقول المصادر انه يجري تحت اشراف قوات
البسيج التي تتركز في قاعده النخبه
الدينيه مشهد
سطعوني على فمي ووصفوني بالسيئه وصوروني
لاقول ان وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيه اثرت علي
للنزول الى الشارع
ليست فاطمه وحدها من تم سحب اعترافات
باطله منها تحت التعذيب في طهران بل الاف
المتظاهرين خصوصا في سنندرج الغربيه ذات
الاغلبيه الكرديه ووفقا للروايات تمثل
المواقع السريه منفذ الاتصال الاول
للمتظاهرين الموقوفين لساعات او لاشهر
لكن مراكز الاعتقال غير الرسميه ليس
الظاهره جديده في ايران الا انها توسعت
كثيرا في الانتفاضه الاخيره
سابقه براي المحللين تعود لخوف النظام من
الاطاحه باركانه ما دفعت به لتكثيف
التكتيكات الوحشيه خارج نطاق الاجراءات
القانونيه وايقاف الاحتجاجات باي ثمن كان
مكرم حناوي العربيه